magnesium is one of the lightest
elements it's right at the beginning of
the periodic table and in fact it's the
first of the light metals that you can
actually use lithium and sodium react
violently with water so you can't really
use them as a metal and beryllium is
fantastically poisonous so unless you're
using it in the lab where you can be
sure that nobody is going to touch it
it's useless so magnesium is the
lightest metal you can use so for
example if you're trying to make mobile
phones that are really light then you
can make the frame of the mobile phone
out of magnesium you can use it for
laptops there's a professor in Germany
who's promised to send me a laptop frame
made of magnesium but hasn't arrived yet
so another classroom classic normally
comes along in chemistry lesson number
three I guess time to combust a reactive
metal in the air so the reactivate our
we're going to look at is magnesium the
other thing that's good about magnesium
is that there's a lot of magnesium about
in the world so it's not an element
that's difficult to get if you look at
this periodic table here which is from
and Barcelona so it's in Catalan the
areas of these each element are
approximately the abundance in the world
some of the rarer elements have a
slightly bigger squares than they should
do so you can read the letters but you
see magnesium here is pretty large so
magnesium and sodium are pretty common
beryllium is much less common and
lithium is even less common than that so
there's lots of bang Museum magnesia is
very light it's very reactive very
pliable metal it's very nice it's easily
alloyed with things like aluminium and
like metals to make very strong very
robust materials used in construction
it's used in high-performance component
of cars when I was a child when we got
had indigestion we were given milk of
magnesia magnesium oxide in water which
came in these really nice blue bottles
sort of white looking liquid didn't
taste very nice but it was meant to be
good for you I'm not sure if it was it's
used in the hulls of ships you know like
warships things like that so incredibly
strong incredibly light but incredibly
reactive if you give it enough energy so
we're going to combust it in your oxygen
and we're going to see what happens
magnesium as you know burns and one of
the reasons ways that magnesium used to
be used was for photographic flashlights
and you use bulbs like these which
contain magnesium inside a bulb filled
with oxygen and for each photograph you
had to put this on the top of the camera
so I've got one here that I've taken out
so if you look at it so much heat has
been produced by this tiny amount of
magnesium that is melted the glass so
let's see what happens when we light it
you can see really fierce bright white
light for that classical glow everyone
seen this in the chemistry lab at school
fantastic reaction it's one of the few
metals which is meant to burn in
nitrogen in theory you can take a piece
of magnesium set fire to it in air so
it's burning well and then plunge it
into nitrogen gas and it should continue
burning I have tried this experiment
lots of times and it's never worked in
fact for 25 years I demonstrated this
lecture this experiment to my lecture
class when I was talking about nitrogen
and every time it didn't work and the
students thought the poor professor has
been made a fool over it hasn't worked
and they didn't know that it never
worked and I would have been more
surprised if it had done but he taught
them a bit about the chemistry of
nitrogen and magnesium why did you keep
doing it I never worked because is a
really good experiment because it got
such a good reaction from the audience
because it went wrong yes you're playing
the fold on purpose yes so this is
magnesium metal but the magnesium metal
here is not the ribbon which we normally
see in perhaps scientific labs or
perhaps in in school labs this is a very
very fine powder of magnesium so what
we're going to do in a moment is we're
going to bring on a really really quite
powerful torch a gas flame and we're
going to see what happens when we
sprinkle a little bit of this material
into the flame magnesium is also very
important in all our lives because
magnesium is found in the green pigments
in the leaves of all plants in
chlorophyll chlorophyll is an organic
molecule carbon hydrogen and nitrogen
and in the middle there is an atom of
magnesium and it is chlorophyll which
captures the sunlight and transfers it
eventually to cause the reaction of
carbon dioxide and water to make all the
sugars and other things in the plant
if that didn't happen none of us would
be alive because we all rely either
directly or indirectly on plants to give
us the energy to live I don't understand
completely the mechanism of
photosynthesis because the energy that's
absorbed by one molecule is transferred
to another another one as it were along
a chain but the magnesium is very
important if you don't have magnesium
there it's not nearly as efficient let's
light it again
you